now we're going to the big daddy
convolutional neural networks
where we're going to
work with the cfa data the image data
set
and at c4 100 there's 100 image classes
and again this data set's available in
keras so we read it in
and we extract just like before
the the training and test data set
and
look at a summary of
of
of what we get
and
as described in the text
there's 50 000 training observations
these are color images and they 32 by 32
but they've got three color channels red
green and blue
so this is a four dimensional array then
this this x
and
and we see the rain the range of any one
of these
these channels
is again 8-bit
one of them here is 13 to 250 d5
255
okay
so the the response is a categorical
variable we're going to one hot encode
that to a hundred column binary matrix
so in the digit data we had a 10 column
binary matrix here we go to a 100 column
binary matrix we love that term one hot
which we learned from our engineering
friends right statistics we used to call
it category we call categorical or dummy
variables which is so boring but one hot
it's
a great you gotta love it you gotta love
it so now we're we're using one hot from
now on yeah
machine learning community has it has a
genius for picking
clever words like deep learning itself
is a brilliant word
okay
so we do that and now we see
that
the
response matrix is fifty thousand by a
hundred
um of course it's very sparse
so
let's look at some of the training
images using
the jpeg package which is a package for
for looking at and manipulating images
so
we just set up a
little framework for doing a little plot
in window five by five we're going to
look at 25 images
we're going to just sample at random
25 of the images and then plot them and
we use plot as raster command
and there we get them
so these images
you know they're small images
right they um what what was the
dimension
32 by 32 emit color images so the
resolution's not that great but they
they
100 different classes sort of natural
images they're plants there's animals
fish
trees
and various things
yeah
okay
so now we set up the model
again using keras model sequential and
now you see the pipe operator really
makes things much clearer here
because there's many layers and we
specify each of the layers
separately
okay
and now we're asking for
convolutional two-dimensional
convolutional filters
and each filter remember each filter was
a little
like a little two by a little
two-dimensional image
in this case they're going to be three
by three images little patches
that we slide along
the the target image
and
do dot products as we're going across
okay
and the first one we say what the
filters look like and we tell it what
the input shape looks like which was 32
by 32 by 3.
okay
and then we have a max pooling layer
which reduces each dimension
of the filtered image
by two a factor of two in each case so
what that recall that what that does is
it takes each non-overlapping two by two
block
and takes the max
because this fault is trying to find
hotspots for certain uh features that it
actually learns in the filter
and then
we repeat this
so we take the the output of the pool in
layer and we apply another filter
and you notice that
we
as the size of these
of these layers as the size of the
images
get smaller the number of hidden units
gets larger this is all described in the
text so we won't go it in detail here
but we just run run this code
and again it's just specifying the model
and now we can do a summary
and you can see the details of each of
these layers
and
we get close to a million parameters
here again astounding with 50 000
training images
okay but if you look here you'll see
there's there's
layers of dropout
throughout
and
yeah you know and so that adds that adds
regularization
all right
so
at the end
we have a dense layer of of size 1024
do we see that yes and then
that gets compressed into another dense
layer of 512 and finally to the output
layer of size 100 because there's a
hundred
images
a hundred classes
and that's
piped into the soft you know that goes
through a soft max layer
for fit in
we'll do ten epochs here and not even
because this takes quite a bit longer to
run because there's a lot of layers lots
of parameters
and
you see the wheel spinning
this progress bar you can see in gray
it's not even it's it's working on the
first epoch
and
when it's finished you see one set of
dots on the on the figure
and on it goes
we're not going to wait for this guy so
i'll just stop it
using that
box there
came up with an arrow we don't care
if you've got time run the whole
model and you'll see it gets an accuracy
of about 46 percent if you trained it to
all the 30 epochs that we were
we intended originally we'd get 46
percent
this is not too bad for 100 class data
but if you search a web currently you'll
find that there are instances of cnns
that can get 75 percent on these data
and it
slowly increases all along as people
introduced different clever tricks and
other bells and whistles which means you
might not believe that we might believe
that 75 right because it's
if they fiddle with the tests if they
should have tested yeah
so yeah
so there's a lot of uh
yeah there are a lot of tricks and yeah
i think that happens right you see these
uh competitions and and you see the
the the leaderboard inches up slowly in
tiny amounts as people come up with new
tricks so is that around the state of
the art for this data set 75 i believe
so 75
yeah
so of course
rob when you when you've got the more
images you have
the more sorry the more classes you have
the harder it is to classify right
because
the the flipper coin classifier on 100
classes
only gets one percent
correct classification 40 is actually
quite good so 40 is not bad yeah
so one nice thing is that
some of these
deep learning networks have been
pre-trained and are available
publicly available and and you can use
them
there's a bigger image
data set called imagenet which has got
millions of images
and has a thousand classes for natural
images
and it's been trained with a very
sophisticated network
and the one we're gonna use is called
resnet
and one can actually use it in
in classifying images
you can actually use it as is out of the
box for classifying images
or you can use some of the
many of the trained layers as a sort of
pre-trained part of your network and
just add layers on top of it
so this is really handy
so
we're gonna what we're gonna do is
we've got a collection of images from
you know of our own from our photograph
album
and we're going to use the pre-trained
network to classify these images
so let me just show you the images
which i've got behind the screen here
so
here we go this is a
image from a photo from from a
photograph album
so you there's a
image of a little lasso abso dog
there's a cat
there's a weaver bird
and
there's a hawk sitting on a fountain
there's a zoomed in version of the hawk
on the fountain and here's some
flamingos
okay so there's
six images and we're going to see
if the
pre-trained network
can actually
classify these images
okay so
we read in the images here's some code
to do that
nothing too complicated
we need to turn the images into a form
that this pre-trained network can
understand so the pre-trained networks
expecting 224 by 224 images these are
high resolution or fairly high
resolution images with three color
channels
and then we turn them into a form that
this
network can understand and so
there's a few commands here that that
are needed to do that
so we just run that
so we've got the images in a directory
the same directory we work in so we can
just read in the images
and so now
we read in the pre-trained model which
is called resnet50 it's a 50
layer
convolutional network and how many
classes were does it or or maybe that's
not relevant it's not
are there a number of classes in the
pre-entry network yes
1000 classes i see so this this is a
data set the imagenet data set
has a thousand clauses and which would
have included things like dogs and birds
and lots of things not just your dogs
but species of dogs and yeah so it's
quite a
quite a extense comprehensive
network so you can see it rather than
we've done a summary
and the summary goes on and on in fact
50 rows
describing all the layers
it's really a complex and this would
have taken this would have been trained
on a massive computers
i believe at google
and uh
and taken a long time to train
but we just make use of it
so
we've got our x matrix now which we
pre-processed
and then we decode the predictions and
we ask for the top three so it's going
to produce a probability for each of the
predictions
and we ask for the top three and have it
print them out
right so
bingo it got the flamingo exactly right
the hawk
it called it a kite
but that's not bad and the other two
guesses were birds as well
house finch seems a bit of a stretch can
we see the picture why did you call it a
kite we
the kite is the type of bird oh actually
there's a fly okay
but in the picture where the
um when you zoomed out it focused on the
fountain rather than the hawk
in fact it didn't see any bird there and
and so classified that as a fountain
right
the lasso apso
it came in second it said tibetan
terrier which looks somewhat similar to
the lhasa apsa is a tibetan
dog
species
and and so it got mixed up with the
tibetan terrier which is pretty good
the cat
to her horror was classified as an old
english sheep dog
next guest was a shitsu dog and the
third was a doormat
luckily the cat can't understand what
we're saying
and the final one was the weaver bird
was classified as a giacomo which does
look somewhat similar anyway i think
that's somewhat of a success
for the pre-trained network